McCABE IS STILL IN EMPLOYEE OF
THE FBI.
>> Jesse: THIS IS JUST
BREAKING.
LISA BLOOM, THE LIBERAL ATTORNEY
WHO REPRESENTED WOMEN ACCUSING
MEN AND HIGH PLACEMENT OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT, LISA BLOOM TALK TO
MISCONDUCT DURING THE LAST FINAL
MONTHS OF THE CAMPAIGN.
SHE WORKED WITH THE TABLOIDS,
WAS GETTING A RIDICULOUS CUT
WHERE SHE COULD SELL THESE
ABILITY IN SOME OF THESE FIELD
ACCUSERS, WE'VE HEARD A LOT
EXPLAIN ALL OF THIS AS TO WHY
SHE WAS HELPING THE WOMEN
BECAUSE THEY MIGHT HAVE TO GET
SECURITY, THEY MIGHT LOSE THEIR
JOB, BE IN BAD FINANCIAL
POSITIONS.
IF YOU HAVE A PROBLEM THAT YOU
WANT TO BRING TO EITHER YOUR
BOSS OR TO THE MEDIA, I WOULD
NOT USE LISA BLOOM AS
REPRESENTATION.
I THINK THAT SHE IS PAST HER
SELL BY DATE.
IT'S THEREFORE EVIDENCE THAT
SOMEHOW THESE WOMEN ARE NOT TO
BE BELIEVED OR THEY WERE OUT
THERE MAKING UP STORIES.
>> Jesse: I DIDN'T SAY IT.
>> Juan: YOU ASKED THE
QUESTION.
WHAT IT IS HIS PEOPLE OFTENTIMES
WILL TRY TO MONETIZE THESE KINDS
OF SCANDALS.
EVEN OUR PRESIDENT HAD A
>> Jesse: PEOPLE SHOP FOR
I'VE HAD IT IN MY POCKET SINCE
YESTERDAY.
>> Kimberly: IT'S MELTED AND
SWEATY?
>> Greg: I PURCHASED THIS
CANDY BAR AND LEAVING IT IN MY
POCKET, I BET IT'S DELICIOUS.
I MIGHT ADD, THIS IS ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF TRANSPARENCY.
THE THING YOU LEARN UNDER A
TRUMP PRESIDENCY, YOU SEE THE
CRONYISM AND THE CORRUPTION,
THIS LEGAL DIRTY TRICKERY WE'VE
NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
IF WE'VE LEARNED ANYTHING FROM
2016 AND 2017, NOTHING IS WHAT
IT SEEMS.
YOU JUST WAIT.
IT TURNS OUT IT'S SOMETHING ELSE
COMPLETELY.
AND YOU REALIZED -- SHE WAS
AGAINST TRUMP, BUT FOR WEINSTEIN
>> Kimberly: TALK ABOUT A
PAYROLL...
>> Dana: SHE HAD TO DISAVOW.
>> Kimberly: IT'S GETTING A
LITTLE MESSY.
>> Dana: SHE WAS ACTIVELY
SEEKING TO DESTROY THE
REPUTATIONS OF SOME OF THE WOMEN
AT WEINSTEIN'S BEHEST.